dozens of drugs deemed critical for
fighting the coronavirus are in short
supply and that's in part because of an
increase in demand but CBS news also
found potential problems in the global
supply chain our consumer investigative
correspondent that's Anna Warner shows
us how the shortage is also affecting
antibiotics and prescription drugs and a
good morning to you a good morning Gail
that's right some people who do not have
covin 19:00 are now dealing with
shortages like one young woman in San
Antonio Texas
not being able to breathe is the most
stressful thing in the world
meet 18-year old Ava Valdez she's a
student who needs an inhaler for allergy
induced asthma allergy this contraption
but due to covert 19 supplies of
albuterol inhaler czar running short so
she's rationing her use to have to wake
up every morning and say okay can I use
this thing that I desperately need and
that will provide me immediate relief is
really frustrating to not know whether
or not I can have that at least one
inhaler manufacturer GlaxoSmithKline
says it has ramped up production of
inhalers to meet increased demand but a
list put together by the resilient drug
supply project at the University of
Minnesota shows of 40 drugs deemed
critical for treatment of kovat 19
patients 30 to 80 percent are in short
supply U of M professor Stephen Shawn de
Meyer and then some drugs as data from
healthcare services company vision shows
demand for three classes of drugs needed
for patients on ventilators was 87
percent higher in April than in January
and just 57 percent of orders placed by
its member hospitals could be filled and
it's not just drugs for kovat 19
treatment Shonda Meyer tracks shortages
on many critical care drugs from
anesthetics to painkillers
why one factor the International supply
chain for pharmaceuticals often leads to
china says author rosemary gibson who
wrote the book china rx China has a
dominant global market share for so many
of the core chemicals and ingredients
for example take antibiotics a
Congressional Research Service report
found the u.s. gets 52 percent of its
penicillin and 90% of its tetracycline
from China China also manufactures
chemicals known as active pharmaceutical
ingredients or api's key ingredients in
drugs when I say China controls our
supply of medicines and dominates the
world supply it's not the finished pills
that we take but it's the core
ingredients the chemicals to make them
will be standing in line with other
countries scrambling to find critical
medicines just as we are for masks and
other protective gear in March the NIH
is dr. Anthony Fauci told members of the
House Appropriations Subcommittee that
health experts have been looking at the
supply chain issue since 2005 something
like 90 percent of the fundamental
ingredients that go into many of the
drugs not the actual drug itself comes
from China so that is a real problem
subcommittee chair representative rosa
DeLauro says it's time to address it the
fact of the matter is that with regard
to drugs generics that whole supply
chain is really where we were very very
dependent on China and that's got to
change
drug manufacturers say they're working
to prevent shortages but there are a
number of complex factors here the group
that represents drug company says its
members make significant investments in
making sure that people have access to
their brand-named medicine scale alright
Anna thank you very much good
information there